et vous avez lui qui a maintenant la
relève qui est arrivé à la tribu marine
brenier notre benjamine de l'assemblée
nationale sophie dion qui s'occupe en
particulier des sports aux républicains
annie genevard pour l'éducation nous
avons guillaume larrivé sur les
questions régaliennes nous avons claude
greff sur les questions sociales et je
vais donc peut-être pas de questions on
va prendre les questions après donc je
vais peut-être proposé à claude de nous
parler des questions de santé ce nouveau
modèle de protection sociale sur lequel
nous avons travaillé dans le cadre de ce
projet merci lui que tout d'abord vous
dire quelle fierté d'avoir pu travailler
avec vous tous
au sein de ces conventions nous avons
aujourd'hui un projet qui est
considérable rarement vue est très riche
avec de nombreuses propositions en
matière de protection sociale
nous avons aujourd'hui un système de
protection sociale qui est extrêmement
généreux mais généreux il a été
malheureusement galvaudé aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement en place puisque ce
principe de solidarité a été quelque peu
changé en assistanat aujourd'hui ce que
nous voulons c'est que ce principe de
système social soit tourner plutôt vers
la fraternité c'est à dire qu' il soit
là solidaires pour tout le monde mais
pour celles et ceux qui en ont besoin
il a été généreux mais malheureusement
il est à bout de souffle pour toutes les
raisons que l'on connaît et il faut
absolument le refonder le refonder
pourquoi il ya d'abord parce qu'on veut
qu'il existe toujours
parce que nous avons aussi parmi nous
des hommes et des femmes qui ont besoin
de ce système social et parce que nous
ne voulons pas que notre jeunesse demain
rembourser cette dette à laquelle nous
sommes malheureusement confronté
eh bien nous avons des solutions
concrètes mais aujourd'hui nous y avons
travaillé avec eric woerth avec toute
l'équipe qui nous a entouré et qui m'a
entouré et bien ces propositions sont
surtout tournés vers les droits et les
devoirs
n'oublions pas
voir les devoirs qui sont les nôtres
nous avons un principe simple qui est
que la protection sociale doit être à
nos côtés mais il faut bannir celles et
ceux qui en font des abus ou toutes
celles et ceux qui fraudent ces
sanctions vont exister aujourd'hui en
tout cas c'est ce que nous voulons et
c'est ce que nous avons comme projet
mais pour cela il faudra simplifier
notre système social
nous avons proposé dans ce projet est
bien une allocation unique
sachez quand même que les allocations
aujourd'hui qui accompagne celles et
ceux qui pourraient en avoir besoin sont
nombreuses
tellement nombreuses qu'elles
complexifie notre système social et qui
génère justement ces abus et c'est
voudras et bien en faisant en créant
cette allocation unique nous rendrons
cette allocation beaucoup plus simple
beaucoup plus abordable par chacun
d'entre nous parce que compréhensible et
en plus de ça nous voulons qu'elles
aient une valeur incitative une valeur
incitative au travail à la reprise du
travail
nous mettrons pour cela évidemment de
nombreuses actions en l'occurrence faire
en sorte que cette allocation unique
bien regroupent et fusionne de très
nombreuses allocations qui sera qui
seront adaptés à notre monde actuel
alors pour cela il faudra évidemment
avoir des objectifs et des conditions
des forts et bien ces conditions
d'efforts elles concerneront celles et
ceux qui sont proches de l'emploi et
bien leur dire que cette allocation ce
soutien lorsqu'elles ont perdu leur
travail
et bien cette allocation ne pourra pas
être pérenne
est très longue nous avons estimé un
temps raisonnable pour celles et ceux
qui sont proches de leur reprise
d'emploi vers six mois et puis il y à
celles et ceux qui ne font pas d'efforts
et ça sera constatée et bien cette
il y aura évidemment la suspension
progressive de cette eau lac allocation
unique et puis et pour celles et ceux
qui sont véritablement très éloigné du
travail et qui n'auront pas la capacité
de pouvoir se remettre sur les rails
et bien il y aura évidemment des heures
d'activité au bénéfice de la
collectivité vous voyez qu'aujourd'hui
on veut une solidarité juste efficace
tournée vers l'emploi et qu'ils soient
justement cohérente
alors cette allocation est ce qu'elle
aura un barème est ce qu'elle aura un
moyen de pouvoir être justifiée et bien
nous ne voulons pas aujourd'hui que
celles et ceux qui bénéficieront de
cette allocation unique puisse être au
delà du smic c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous donnerons évidemment une
gestion au caf associé au pôle emploi
pour que tout cela soit mieux
appréhender la verse le versement de
cette allocation puisse est fait par la
caf en accord avec pôle emploi avec un
volet insertion et un volet un volet
formation voilà luxe que je voulais dire
mais je pourrais répondre à d'autres
questions
merci claude je salue françoise guégot
sébastien huyghe eric ciotti qui
complète la tribune
alors je vais prendre deux questions 30
secondes chacun
vas-y bonjour à tous donc à neiger à nos
départements 35 ille et vilaine donc moi
je voulais aborder la question de la
santé puisque j'ai la pratique du
terrain tant que directrice d'hôpital
euh en fait je voulais déjà salué le
fait que dans le projet lié à un axe
pour réinvestir le champ social parce
qu'il faut surtout pas en faire
l'apanage de la gauche et il faut
surtout qu'on puisse nous aussi pouvoir
proposer ses solutions concrètes sur un
sujet si important
alors je vais effectivement raccourcir
mon intervention pour poser deux
questions la première c'est comment
favoriser la modernisation de l'hôpital
public parce qu'on voit bien que la
récente loi de modernisation de santé
n'a rien apporté
elle n'a porté que de la technocratie de
la lourdeur et ne répond pas du tout à
l'objet de refondation de notre système
social est ma deuxième question il sera
aussi très simple face au défi du
vieillissement et des pathologies
chroniques
comment prendre en compte aussi
indépendamment du plan autisme et du
plan alzheimer la question de la santé
mentale qui au vu des prévalences
importante dans la population et des
enjeux représentent aussi un enjeu
considérable
merci je rebondis tout de suite
deuxième question micron pleut et je
roule jce je veux lui d'informer ceux
qui sont debout
la tribune a été ouverte donc vous
pourrez être beaucoup mieux installés
que debout au fond de la salle premier
étage alexandre abord piot concert
départementale des alpes-maritimes j'ai
une question en matière d'éducation
puisque eric ciotti
la présidence de cette commission cent
mille jeunes sortent donc chaque année
comme vous le savez sans diplôme de leur
scolarité pas moins d'un élève sur cinq
sort du collège sans maîtriser les
fondamentaux un bilan donc
catastrophique qui ne confère évidemment
une grande responsabilité
la réussite des célèbes des élèves vous
le savez doit être notre priorité
absolue parce qu'elle est la promesse
d'un avenir meilleur pour nos enfants
alors face à ce constat alarmant
comment nous allons pouvoir comment nous
nous allons pouvoir refonder l'école et
restaurer l'autorité et revenir donc aux
fondamentaux de l'école républicaine
merci tout de suite annie jeu de 20
bateaux répondent il ya peut-être une
dernière question c'est sûr même sujet
même sujet alors vas-y 30 secondes
merci marie france marie françoise marie
françoise nadau conseillère régionale
nouvelle aquitaine et président de la
fédération lundi républicains
ma question concerne aussi l'éducation
l'apprentissage qui est annoncé comme
une voie d'excellence
malheureusement c'est un effet d'annoncé
la réalité loin puisque nous peinons à
voir depuis 2012 dépasser le chiffre de
400 mille apprentis alors qu'il est de
la millions 4 en allemagne
donc ma question est comment le système
éducatif est bien ne relève plus loin là
l'apprentissage comme
formation en fonds de fonds de choix
négatif en choix par défaut
comment offert que nos jeunes
choisissent leur orientation
le système ne fonctionne plus
l'apprentissage des ne décolle plus
quelles sont les solutions que vous
allez apporter
merci marie françoise annie genevard
notre délégué général chargé des
questions d'éducation pour vous répondre
merci monsieur le président alors c'est
vrai que nous avons beaucoup travaillé
sur l'éducation vous avez pu voir que
l'éducation est entrée dans le débat
public avec les trois ministres qui se
sont succédés en quatre ans sans que il
ne nous est donné la preuve que les
politiques qui l'ont mis en oeuvre qui
l'ont mise en oeuvre était vraiment
efficace alors notre école est à la
peine notre école est à la peine et il
faut dire que tous les deux ans il y a
en moyenne depuis 1958 une réforme
scolaire
cela veut dire que si nous réformons et
nous réformerons l'école et il faut le
faire avec beaucoup beaucoup de soin et
en priorisant véritablement les choix
qui seront utiles à notre école tout
d'abord ce que je voudrais dire c'est
que il faut se donner comme priorité
absolue de rendre à l'école sa mission
première qui est celle de transmettre
des savoirs
nous sommes dans une véritable crise de
transmission des savoirs najat vallaud
belkacem et ceux qui l'ont précédé ont
porté une atteinte énorme à la
transmission des savoirs aux disciplines
ils ont un art consommé ces socialistes
de mettre fin à ce qui marche bien nous
avions mis en oeuvre les classes
bilangues les sections européennes
voilà qui est supprimé d'un trait plumes
en dépit des succès que cela nouvelle
est je ne parle pas de
la mise à mal d'un anciennement
séculaire qui est celui des langues
anciennes
et puis bien sûr vous avez évoqué madame
la question des savoirs fondamentaux
tout se joue dans les premières années
notamment avec l'apprentissage de la
lecture
et là je crois qu'il faut véritablement
s'il y a une priorité elle se donne et
c'est celle-là c'est rendre efficace
plus efficace l'apprentissage de la
lecture et repositionner l'apprentissage
dans la langue fraude de la langue
française comme quelque chose de
absolument fondamental c'est la raison
pour laquelle c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous proposons d'augmenter
effectivement les heures d'enseignement
du français pour les élèves qui sont en
difficulté de proposer un cp plus de
mettre fin aux enseignements
communautaire délivrés dans les locaux
qui sont un véritable scandale délivré
dans nos classes dans nos écoles
républicaines par deux professeurs qui
ne parlent pas le français et dont on ne
peut pas contrôler la teneur du message
il faut aussi l'école c'est un lieu
d'affirmation de nos valeurs les valeurs
sont celles de l'excellence et du mérite
et là encore les socialistes ont mis fin
à des dispositifs qui fonctionnait bien
je pense notamment aux internats de
l'excellence ou aux bourses au mérite
il est invraisemblable que nous ayons
mis fin à ces dispositifs qui était
utile et qui avait fait qu'ils avaient
fait leurs preuves
l'école est un lieu d'apprentissage des
vies que de la vie commune ne sait
pourquoi nous voulons aussi que les
rites collectif que la reconnaissance du
mérite puisse être véritablement
partagée par la communauté scolaire et
puis enfin le dernier point très
rapidement lui qu il faut améliorer la
performance de notre système éducatif
quelle humiliation mes chers amis quelle
humiliation lorsque les
les évaluations internationales nous
relègue adhérents indigne de la france
indigne de l'argent que la france
consacre à l'éducation
c'est une honte et il faut améliorer la
performance de notre système éducatif
et puis je dirais pour finir parce que
c'est d'actualité
le gouvernement est en train de mettre à
mal une liberté fondamentale consacré
depuis 1880 en france qui est la liberté
d'enseignement
les socialistes veulent lui porter
atteinte vous voyez que ils ne sont
jamais en panne d'idées pour mettre à
mal notre système éducatif qui devrait
être au contraire notre fierté notre
ambition est en tout cas c'est à ça que
nous nous attellerons lorsque nous
reviendrons aux affaires merci à vie
sébastien huyghe notre traiteur général
adjoint voulait compléter une minute sur
l'apprentissage
oui j bastien la question portait
également sur l'apprentissage
l'apprentissage est effectivement une
filière d'excellence qui mène à
pratiquement à coup sûr à un emploi il
faut savoir que nos jeunes selon les
filières au bout de six mois après
l'obtention de leur diplôme à 70 à 80 %
auquel un emploi nicolas sarkozy pendant
son quinquennat avait fait décoller
l'apprentissage malheureusement françois
hollande en arrivant au pouvoir comme
dans beaucoup de domaines a mis à mal
tout ce qui avait été fait sous le
quinquennat précédent par certains v10
antisarkozysme primaire je suis plutôt
de ceux qui disent par antisarkozysme
pathologique et donc c'est aujourd'hui à
nous dans les régions de reprendre le
flambeau pour développer l'apprentissage
donc nous région par région en tout cas
pour celles que nous convenons nous
mettons en place des plans de
développement de l'apprentissage
le problème auquel on est confronté
c'est que pour que l'apprentissage
d'école il faut des mesures pérennes
on ne peut pas avoir une année telle
mesure une autre année on revient en
arrière et on va dans un sens différent
ce que les ce dont les entreprises ont
besoin pour pouvoir prendre des
apprentis
c est sûr que la règle qui est fixé et
bien sera pérenne
pendant l'intégralité du mandat des élus
qui les prennent et donc ce que nous
ferons pour l'apprentissage c'est dès le
début du prochain quinquennat mettre en
place des mesures pérennes qui font que
les entreprises vont pouvoir gérer leur
politique d'apprentissage sur la durée
merci sébastien alors pendant qu'eric
ciotti se prépare je salue l'arrivée de
nathalie kosciusko morizet de michèle
tabarot de notre porte parole guillaume
pelletier eric ciotti c'est à toi
monsieur le président le temps est venu
ce soir nous aurons un projet nous
aurons un projet clair audacieux
ambitieux courageux pour préparer
l'alternance
cette alternance 14 qu'exige nos
concitoyens ce projet il fait suite à
toutes les étapes qui nous ont permis de
reconstruire notre famille politique
celle des nouveaux statuts celle de
l'organisation et de l'élection des
fédérations celle de la conquête des
territoires aux départementales aux
régionales celle de la préparation des
primaires
cette équipe ce parti ce mouvement est
aujourd'hui en ordre de marche mais
surtout mais surtout il a un chef qui a
ouvert cette refondation qui a
reconstruit cette famille qui lui a
donné de la force
nicolas sarkozy
mais fi merci à nicolas sarkozy d'avoir
avec la détermination et l'énergie qu'on
lui connaît fait le choix de
l'engagement au service de notre famille
politique
alors oui ce projet va constituer ce
socle de cette alternance que nos
français que les français réclament ce
projet il intervient à un moment
particulièrement éprouvant pour notre
nation un moment tragique
quelque part le terrorisme nous menace
l'économie est en faillite
la voix de la france à l'international
s'est éteint la nation et des agrégés
par les divisions et par le critt
spectacle de ceux qui nous gouvernent
alors oui c'est à nous qu'appartient la
responsabilité de relever les défis de
l'avenir de l'espérance de l'alternance
nous aurons à répondre à deux questions
essentielles
deux questions que se posent nos
concitoyens celle du déclin économique
avec un une interrogation sur l'avenir
est ce que nos enfants vivront mieux
demain et bien pour la première fois
depuis sans doute plusieurs générations
les français sont convaincus que demain
leurs enfants vivront moins bien que
c'est une préoccupation de tous les
instants
une autre question majeure est posée par
nos concitoyens
celle de l'avenir de notre nation de la
fidélité à nos racines
un autre mode de vie à notre culture à
notre identité qui appelle à se demander
si demain la france sera toujours la
france alors oui nous avons le devoir la
responsabilité l'immense responsabilité
de répondre à ces questions
aujourd'hui nous le savons l'autorité
n'est plus incarné à la tête de l'état
le président de la république recule
devant leonarda le premier ministre
capitule devant les syndicats le
ministre de l'inter
elle autorise les casseurs a cassé le
ministre de la justice parle de
clochardisation de la justice la
ministre de l'éducation remet en cause
les notes lemery l'excellence des
quartiers sont livrés à la loi de la
jungle et des trafiquants des zones de
non droit comme à calais se sont
installés au coeur de notre république
livrée aux mafias de passeurs et les
règles religieuses trop souvent s'impose
aujourd'hui aux lois de la république
alors oui il n'est que temps de mettre
un terme à l'imposture de françois
hollande et du gouvernement socialiste
oui il occupe malgré sa taille un
costume beaucoup trop grand pour lui
c'est à l'état c'est à l'état mes chers
amis qu'ils appartiennent de restaurer
l'autorité de la république
l'autorité ce n'est pas permettre les
rassemblements de boue la nuit est
couché le jour les autorités
ce n'est pas de laisser la cgt bloquer
notre pays et porter atteinte à
l'hôpital des enfants l'hôpital necker
là où était hospitalisé ce petit enfant
qui a été témoin de l'assassinât de ses
deux parents policiers sans réaction du
ministre de l'intérieur
l'autorité de l'état ce n'est pas au
moment où notre pays est au coeur de la
menace terroriste
laissez porter atteinte à l'honneur des
policiers des gendarmes et de ce qui
nous protège en ne déposant pas plainte
contre les deux affiches de la cgt et du
maire de grenoble
nous demandons au ministre de
l'intérieur
de déposer plainte contre ceux qui
portent atteinte aux policiers
l'autorité de la république c'est
choisir librement qui on souhaite
accueillir sur notre territoire nous
avons dans ce projet définit la le sens
d'une politique migratoire enfin
responsable avec des quotas migratoires
avec la capacité d'intégration avec une
refonte de notre droit de la nationalité
comme le disait tout à l'heure
notre président l'autorité s'est enfin
défendre la laïcité sans ambiguïté
contre les communautarismes contre les
tyrannies des minorités et les velléités
de plus en plus manifeste de certains de
construire des contres société c'est
pour cela que personnellement j'ai
défendu à l'assemblée nationale une
proposition de loi visant à interdire le
port du voile à l'université parce que
pour moi
l'université est par excellence le lieu
de la modernité de la science du progrès
des lumières et que l'université ne peut
pas être soumise à quelques superstition
ou à quelques règles religieuses
alors oui nous avons aussi le devoir de
mieux protéger nos concitoyens
l'autorité c'est faire en sorte que
contre le terrorisme on ne soit plus
naïve alors que nous connaissons ce qui
représente une menace
cela a toujours été le cas pour les
auteurs de tous les attentats qui ont
frappé notre pays depuis un an et demi
nous demandons et nous l'avons fait avec
guillaume larrivé dans une récente
proposition de loi que tout cela tous
ceux qui présentent une menace soient
placés dans des centres de rétention
oui nous voulons aujourd'hui affirmer et
je veux affirmer des convictions fortes
pour ma part je le dis je suis de droite
je le revends dis je la fum nous aurons
ensemble autour de ses valeurs de la
droite républicaine à bâtir
l'alternance cette alternance de devons
nous y préparer
nous devons aussi conjurer quelques
menaces qui nous guette
je le dis très clairement cette
alternance ne doit pas être une énième
fois le choix d'un changement non le
choix de 2017 c'est plus que cela c'est
d'abord le choix de la france
le choix de l'âme française c'est la
volonté de relever la tête et de la
garder bien haute
si nous échouons mes amis nous ouvriront
la porte aux dangers des extrêmes et du
front national
c'est pour cela que nous avons ce devoir
de réussite et je veux mettre en garde
aussi contre un second danger c'est
celui de se laisser dérobé nos choix par
d'autres oui
ne nous laissons pas imposer nos choix
par d'autres prenons garde que derrière
le masque du consensus se cache le
danger de la confusion
nous n'avons pas besoin de la confusion
la droite ce n'est pas la gauche nous
n'avons rien à voir avec eux disons le
clairement nous ne gouvernerons jamais
dans quelque circonstance que ce soit
avec la gauche oui mes amis une vague va
se tourner
cette page nicolas sarkozy a commencé à
l'écrire avec le courage la force et la
capacité que nous attendons d'un chef
qui ouvre la route
merci à nicolas sarkozy de nous avoir
montré le cap
oui il faut reprendre le fil du roman
national
le retour de la droite que nous
incarnons doit être avant tout le retour
de la france merci pendant que je
philippe richert se prépare à monter sur
la scène
je voudrais juste deux minutes philippe
que sophie dion no10 un mode un sujet
auquel notre président est très attaché
c'est la politique sportive de notre
projet mes chers amis
alors c'est vrai c'est une confidence
vous savez que notre président nicolas
sarkozy aime particulièrement le sport
en général et le football en particulier
mais j'aimerais rappeler ce que beaucoup
de responsables politiques et de médias
ont oublié de préciser et ce depuis le
10 juin dernier
si nous avons la grande chance de vivre
cette grande fête populaire de l'euro
en ce moment c'est avant tout grâce à
nicolas sarkozy
c'est parce qu'il s'était impliqué
personnellement dans ce dossier et qu'il
avait arraché la décision d'obtention de
l'euro un vendredi matin ce 28 mai 2010
en se déplaçant lui même car il a mis en
place deux ans entre 2007 et 2012
une véritable stratégie d'accueil des
grands événements sportifs en france
outre l'obtention de l'euro-2016 notre
pays à organiser et organisera de
nombreux championnats internationaux
il ya eu des succès il y en aura
d'autres est ce que vous je voulais vous
dire c'est dans le cadre du projet sport
il s'agira donc en premier lieu de
remettre à l'ordre du jour c'est
politique d'accueil des grands
événements sportifs
qui s'était avéré si efficace avec pour
objectif numéro 1 bien sûr de se voir
attribuer les jeux olympiques d'été en
2024 ici même à paris cher david
douillet le sport c'est un atout c'est
une chance c'est un investissement
c'est sur l'avenir et ça n'est pas une
charge le sport figurez-vous c'est le
premier parti de france
il a 16 millions de licenciés 34
millions de sympathisants et c'est aussi
le premier des mouvements associatifs
c'est un fait social majeur il est le
miroir de toutes les difficultés de tous
les maux mais aussi de toutes les
espérances et des réussites d'une
société et le pouvoir ce pouvoir du
sport et est immense il a selon les
mondes de nelson mandela le pouvoir de
changer le monde
alors si la marseillaise résonne et si
le drapeau français flotte sur les
podiums c'est aussi parce que dans un
club un jour un bénévole à emmener un
enfant pour donner de son temps dans une
compétition dans un district et dans le
cadre de notre projet sport 2017
nous parlerons beaucoup de l'engagement
associatif et des bénévoles pour
conclure juste un mot je vous remercie
pour votre attention et surtout je
voulais souhaité au nom des républicains
et de vous tous bonne chance à l'équipe
de france qui affronte demain l'islande
en quarts de finale de l'euro merci à
vous tous merci merci sophy j'appelle
philippe richert président de la région
grand est président de l'association des
régions de france à venir s'exprimer
chers amis ni
la dernière fois que je m'étais exprimé
à une tribune du conseil national
c'était avant les élections et nous
étions engagés avec deux belles équipes
cher valérie pour essayer de conquérir
ce grand est alsace lorraine champagne
ardenne ce n'était pas facile
je vais vous dire nous avons gagné
aujourd'hui nous construisons le
construisant à la fois en regardant ce
que nous avons trouvé comme héritage en
particulier en lorraine champagne
ardenne les séparent les socialistes
n'avons pas été déçus et nous pouvons
comparer puis surtout aujourd'hui nous
essayons de donner de l'ambition du
sérieux et aussi de la solidarité en
particulier pour les territoires ruraux
fragiles dans des moments compliqués
pour l'agriculture et pour tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui ont affronté la difficulté
de la croissance mais dans cette région
grand est alsace champagne-ardennes
lorraine nos voisins bien sûr c'est les
autres pensées ile de france franche
comté bourgogne mais nos voisins c'est
aussi la belgique le luxembourg
l'allemagne avec bagur tambay rhénanie
palatinat et la suisse nous avons trop
souvent l'habitude de le comparer à nous
mêmes entre nous lorsque vous vous
comparer aux voisins
les quatre frontières pour comprenez
vite la désillusion qui nous touche
le déclassement aujourd'hui est en route
pour la france
et quand j'entends la cour des comptes
et lorsque je regarde la situation en
comparaison avec nos voisins que ce soit
dans le domaine du chômage du
développement économique mais aussi du
lien social
la peur que j'ai
la crainte que j'ai c'est qu'en réalité
lorsque demain cher nicolas
chers amis nous aurons à exercer des
responsabilités nationales
nous allons découvrir que la situation
est beaucoup plus grave que ce que nous
imaginons parce que la situation qu'ils
vont nous laisser est une situation
dégradée dans tous les domaines
financiers on l'a entendu la cour des
comptes économiques sociales
il n'y a plus de dialogue et bien sûr de
sécurité il ya dans ce bilan que je dois
tirer sur ses quatre ans de gauche
un seul élément favorable un seul sait
qu'ils ont démontré que c'est avec eux
que nous allons pouvoir construire
l'avenir
chers amis nous savions que la situation
était difficile
la seule chose aujourd'hui qui vient se
rajouter à cette certitude c'est que
c'est pas avec la gauche que nous allons
trouver des solutions jusqu'à présent
nous avions la conviction que la
solution se trouverait par l'est
républicain par la droite et le centre
aujourd'hui nos concitoyens le savent il
suffit de regarder les résultats des
sondages du chef de l'état jamais dans
notre pays nous avons été dans une
situation à ce niveau dégradé oui
aujourd'hui nous savons tous que la
poursuite de cette convergence
socialiste est d'une gravité extrême et
il nous faut aujourd'hui reconstruire en
projet pour permettre de regarder
l'avenir est dans cette situation
difficile
dans cette situation nous savons bien
qu'il faudra remettre en place un projet
qui donne de l'ambition qui donne la
confiance est arrivé le brésil seul art
pour nous chacun le sait
des conséquences difficiles à évaluer
mais ce que nous savons d'ores et déjà
c'est qu'il faudra refonder l'europe
comme le président sarkozy l'avait dit
lorsqu'il était à berlin
nous savions tous que leurs hommes
n'allaient pas bien la différence est
qu'aujourd'hui nous savons que nous ne
pouvons plus reculer qu'il s'agit de
refonder avec courage les principes même
de la construction européenne d'un
mesdames et messieurs chers amis demain
gagné cette consultation gagner la
présidentielle
ce n'est pas simplement une obligation
pour nous pour nos valeurs pour notre
projet autour duquel je vous invite tous
à nous retrouver parce que c'est un vrai
projet à la foire qui reprend nos
valeurs et qui le donne ses perspectives
mes chers amis ce n'est pas que pour le
projet
ce n'est pas que pour les républicains
c'est vraiment de la france dont il
s'agit chacun sait aujourd'hui que la
seule issue possible
c'est que nous soyons demain en capacité
de redonner l'espoir de retracer les
perspectives et de mettre en pratique ce
que nous avons ici construit ensemble
c'est pour cela qu'il est important que
nous soyons unis que nous sachions nous
rassembler et que nous sachions
construire ce projet qui demain
redonnera des couleurs à la france
ce n'est pas nicolas oui et philippe
philippe reste debout
j'aurais dire une chose parce que tout
le monde ne connaît pas comme je le
connais il très important pour nous
d'abord parce qu'il est de la tradition
centriste qui a été loyal à notre
famille politique ce n'est pas ma
famille d'origine
mais on est bien content de t'avoir les
deuxièmement à toi comme athée
colistiers mais beaucoup de gens qui
parlent qui font des déclarations lui
hissé battue face au socialiste et face
au front national avec ses colistiers
cher valérie est aujourd'hui la
champagne ardenne la lorraine et
l'alsace est présidée par l'un de
l'autre
merci philippe richert alors françoise
guégot vice-président de la région
normandie voulait compléter un petit mot
françoise oui un tout petit mot je
voudrais évidemment rebondir sur ce que
vient de dire notre ami philippe nous
sommes un certain nombre grâce à vous et
je voudrais en profiter pour vous
remercier tous parce que nous savons que
ces régions ces régions que nous avons
gagné parfois de manière un petit peu
difficile
nous les avons gagné parce que nous
avons été capables de nous réunir de
travailler ensemble d'avoir des relais
sur le terrain des militants une
organisation de notre famille politique
qui a été remis en ordre de marche et à
mon tour je voudrais aussi bien sûr
remercié nicolas de nous avoir permis de
réaliser ce travail et lui dire que si
aujourd'hui nous avons évidemment
travailler tous au titre des différents
mandats qui sont les nôtres à ce projet
à ce projet qui est pour nous un moment
majeur de de la vie d'un parti politique
mais bien sûr un moment majeur pour la
politique française de demain
cette déclinaison elle se fera aussi
avec les politiques régionales et nous
avons souffert entre 2007 et 2012 et je
prendrai un très court exemple qui est
un sujet que je connais bien sûr
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
nous avons souffert sur une loi qui a
été absolument fondamental évidemment
porté par notre président et qui a été
défendu très largement par valérie
pécresse tout d'abord et ensuite laurent
wauquiez nous avons eu beaucoup de mal à
réaliser certaines déclinaisons parce
que nous n'avions pas les régions et
parce que nous n'avions pas ce levier
des politiques territoriales
aujourd'hui nous avons évidemment de
grandes régions nous avons la
possibilité de faire de grandes choses
pour que ces grandes choses se réalisent
il faut que nous ayons une coordination
entre notre politique nationale il n'y a
pas parlé d'un côté et nos territoires
de l'autre il y a une réelle conjonction
à mettre en oeuvre il y a des valeurs à
défendre on parlait tout à l'heure de
l'apprentissage
nous avons lancé en normandie et je
voudrais saluer mon collègue david
margueritte qui l'a vice président en
charge de ces questions un grand
grenelle de l'apprentissage
l'apprentissage est un sujet majeur
mais cet apprentissage nous le régleront
à la fois avec les politiques
territoriales mais aussi avec des
modifications
évidemment législatives demain donc nous
avons besoin de cette coordination de
cette de ce travail ensemble des
politiques territoriales et de notre
engagement national voilà donc c'est
évidemment avec vous que nous allons
pouvoir réaliser ce nouveau combat ce
nouveau travail et je crois que c'est
absolument essentiel pour mettre en
oeuvre une france rénovée une france
attractive parce que cette attractivité
nous la réaliserons au plus profond de
nos territoires
merci françoise la parole est maintenant
à brice hortefeux
chers amis voici à nouveau réunis pour
un conseil national mais un conseil
national bien particulier pas seulement
parce que nous avons accueilli elle nous
avons accueilli et applaudi le trésorier
ce qui mène n'est pas très fréquent dans
les familles politiques mais surtout
particulier par le symbole qu'ils
portent
c'est à dire celui d'une famille
politique qui a voulu et su réfléchir à
ce qu'elle voulait pour notre pays
près d'un an avant les grandes échéances
et les grands rendez vous et si vous me
passez l'expression je pense que c'est
quasiment unique d'être aussi près aussi
loin alors aujourd'hui c'est un jour
aussi heureux et je pense que l'on a
tout intérêt à le revendiquer et
l'assumé heureux parce que notre famille
qui fut traversé hier par le poison de
la division menacée d'éclatement et en
vérité condamné si cela avait persisté à
la disparition
heureusement pour empêcher ce qui nous
aurait perdu chacun chacun a apporté sa
pierre
il est vrai que pour quelques insectes
et parfois des petits cailloux
mais quelle que soit notre engagement
reconnaissons à nicolas sarkozy le
courage avoir pris sur ses épaules la
responsabilité difficile sans doute un
gradient françois mais certainement
indispensable de chef de l'opposition
un chef pas autoproclamé les un chef élu
qui est aujourd'hui le ciment de notre
unité en ayant rassemblé autour de la
table tous ceux qui voulaient la
renverser mais aujourd'hui oui eric
nadine l'on dit c'est aussi un temps
difficile difficile pour notre pays qui
offrent le spectacle affligeant d'un
état sans tête sans direction sans
boussole à l'autorité déliquescente d'un
gouvernement qui oscille comme le
pendule entre coups de menton et genou
qui flanche et d'une majorité qui
élection après élection mesure qu'elle
ne l'est plus la vérité c'est que c'est
la pagaille à tous les étages le
désordre partout et la justice nulle
part de la sphère leonarda roger où
effectivement une gamine en situation
illégale se moque publiquement du chef
de l'état sans véritable réaction
hormis une imitation à vrai dire assez
réussie de nicolas canteloup d'un ancien
ministre
aujourd'hui commissaire européen qui
affirme je cite ne pas croire aux
racines chrétiennes de l'europe
oubliant que pendant près de milan le
christianisme a été le fait dominant de
la vie de notre continent et sans que
cela suscite un mot un seul mot de
condamnation ou même à minima un rappel
de vérité historique des manifestations
de policiers qui attendait tout
simplement de recevoir en
un des consignes claires et qui
d'ailleurs les attendent toujours de la
passivité face au mouvement de ceux qui
pas tous mais beaucoup touchent les
allocations le jour et passent la nuit
debout des manifestations interdites
hanover est autorisé à 12h du mutisme
français face à la décision ubuesque de
l'exécutif européen menaçant de rétablir
les visas pour les ressortissants
américains et canadiens tandis qu'on les
supprimerait pour les turcs du silence
assourdissant du chef de l'état alors
que voici tout juste 48 heures tout
juste a été ouvert un nouveau chapitre
le chapitre numéro 33 en vue de
l'adhésion de la turquie à laquelle il
appartient naturellement à l'opposition
de s'opposer clairement et
définitivement
bref tout démontre jour après jour dans
cette ambiance crépusculaire que c'est
le début de la fin pour eux et pourtant
cela ne les empêche pas de tenter deux
derniers tours de passe-passe et celle
qu'un eric en matière d'immigration
aujourd'hui écouter les écouter les
biens l'immigration c'est la
responsabilité de l'europe
rien que de l'europe toujours de
l'europe il est vrai que c'est l'europe
qui a enregistré 1 million 800 mille
franchissement illégaux en 2015 c'est
vrai que c'est l'europe qui est passé de
450 mille demandeurs d'asile en 2013 un
million deux cent mille en 2015 que
c'est vrai que c'est en europe que plus
de 250 mille migrants encore tenter
d'arriver par mer depuis de l'année
mais à ma connaissance la politique
migratoire s'est d'abord aussi et
surtout une volonté politique nationale
est là la vérité c'est qu'on en parle
plus parce qu'il n'y en a plus oubliée
la circulaire de manuel valls augmentant
les régularisations de clandestins de
52% oublier l'acquisition facilité de la
nationalité française en augmentation de
près de 27% entre 2013 et 2015
et l'europe je vous liez sur ce sujet
c'est un bouc émissaire facile pour
marquer sa propre impuissance
alors chers amis comme david douillet
l'a dit je partage son opinion
les semaines qui viennent pourront être
le meilleur comme le pire pour nous le
pire si nous étalons des divisions et
nous complaisons dans de vraies fausses
petites phrases qui se veulent
assassines et autour de nicolas sarkozy
nous nous aurait nous nous y refusons
pour aujourd'hui comme pour demain mais
ça peut être aussi le meilleur le
meilleur si nous savons nous rassembler
sans état d'âme au tour de celui que
vous aurez choisi
pour redresser notre pays alors en
conclusion tous ensemble je vous propose
d'une page oubliée l'adresse aux
pèlerins d'emmaüs annie il se fait tard
restons ensemble merci mme rice avant de
libérer nos secrétaires nationaux qui
sont à la tribune peut-être une question
micro bleus merci luc un des enjeux est
à mon sens de l'alternance de 2017 le
monde te connais francs voire deux ans
que secrétaire départemental de la corse
du sud inde et un des messages qui me
semble devoir être inscrit au coeur de
notre projet d'alternance c'est le
message à notre jeunesse et je pense
qu'on sait pas ces dernières années a
s'est adressé aux jeunes et notamment à
tous ceux qui étudient qui qui sont
vraiment l'honneur de notre système
éducatif et qui malheureusement ne
trouvent pas de travail ne trouvent pas
de travail dans notre pays et sont
obligés de s'expatrier
quand allons-nous leur proposer des
vraies solutions quand vont-ils vraiment
être une richesse une valeur ajoutée
pour notre économie et je pense que
notre mouvement a tout intérêt à se
consacrer à et à trouver une réponse
voilà merci franck marine tu veux dire
un mot là-dessus
oui merci luc merci franck pour cette
question simplement avant de répondre
mais je vais tenter d'être brève
je voulais remercier à la fois le
président du conseil nationale luc
chatel
et le président de notre famille
politique nicolas sarkozy car il y avait
une volonté affirmée de notre jeunesse
des jeunes républicains de pouvoir
s'exprimer depuis longtemps au conseil
national
c'est vrai que nous n'avions plus
l'occasion de le faire et grâce à luc
chatel et à nicolas sarkozy
aujourd'hui ma présence à cette tribune
et le témoignage de cette volonté qu'ils
ont eue de pouvoir redonner une voix à
leur jeunesse et je tenais vraiment à
les remercier pour ce choix courageux
merci tu avais plus est en temps de
perdre autant parole marianne japon je
vais être rapide
franck c'est une question intéressante
c'est vrai il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
décident de s'expatrier et on constate
aujourd'hui près de huit personnes sur
dix qui décident de s'expatrier sont des
jeunes
alors on a eu la chance d'avoir un
programme qui s'appelle erasmus qui
fonctionne bien qui fonctionne bien
notamment grâce à la majorité qui était
conduite par le gouvernement de nicolas
sarkozy
ce programme fonctionne bien permet à
nos étudiants balle est ronde aller
étudier à l'étranger et à des étudiants
étrangers de venir travailler en france
mais une fois que ce parcours étudiant
et réaliser que nos jeunes sont diplômés
effectivement ils ne trouvent plus de
travail ici en france et on a beaucoup
qui partent à londres à new york ou dans
d'autres pays dans lesquels aujourd'hui
il est plus facile de trouver du travail
quand on est diplômé alors on a la
chance d'avoir des collectivités
certaines collectivités
je vous cache pas que la plupart sont de
notre couleur politique qui décide de
mettre en place des pépinières
d'entreprises qui valorise les start up
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
signal qu'il faut envoyer à françois
hollande lui expliquer que la jeunesse
qui est diplômée elle aime la france
mais aujourd'hui elle est obligée de la
quitter elle aimerait qu'une seule chose
est de pouvoir y rester et pour ça il
faut faire en sorte de développer des
programmes intéressants pour pouvoir
développer des start up pour pouvoir
développer des filières innovantes
telles que celle du développement
durable ou celle des nouvelles
technologies alors vous l'avez remarqué
certainement il n'y a pas de chapitre
qui est directement porté sur la
jeunesse dans le programme des
républicains pour une raison simple
cette raison c'est que
le président de notre famille politique
nicolas sarkozy a décidé de faire
confiance à la jeunesse et nous avons
mis en place des réflexions dans la
quasi totalité des fédérations des
jeunes républicains en france sous la
tutelle des lâches halki monsieur le
président votre vice présidente à la
région alsace lorraine champagne ardenne
el zhar a fait un très gros travail avec
nos militants et dès le mois de
septembre et c'est aussi l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles je souhaitais
intervenir aujourd'hui dès le mois de
septembre je vous l'annoncé lors du
campus national des jeunes républicains
et oui il y en aura de nouveau un il se
tiendra le premier week-end de septembre
à marseille et vous êtes évidemment tous
invités à y participer merci marine pour
cette annonce paroissiale alors je vous
propose de rester à la tribune le temps
que nous écoutions michèle alliot marie
que j'appelle à nous rejoindre sur la
scène on fera la relève à l'issue du
discours de michel
chers amis bonjour nous voici c'est vrai
tous ensemble à de nouvelles heures de
crise d'incertitude le terrorisme les
tensions mondiales le break si les
crispations sociales contestation de
l'autorité de l'état la crédibilité des
médias mis en cause la crédibilité des
hommes et des femmes politiques mis en
cause aussi dans de tels moments
oui c'est vrai il est bon de se
retrouver en famille de voir au delà de
nos différences
ce qui nous réunit c'est à dire notre
volonté de vivre ensemble et
conformément à nos valeurs dans de tels
moments
il est indispensable de se retrouver
pour se référer à ce qui est immuable
essentiel fondamental
alors ce matin je suis venu vous parler
de la france de notre france de ma
france
la france qui protège lorsque nous mêmes
nous la rendons forte la france qui nous
unit lorsque nous avons dépassé nos
querelles nos petites phrases brice nos
égoïsmes nos petites ambitions et c'est
à ce niveau que se situe le projet
présidentiel
un projet ce sont des propositions
concrètes telles que celles que vous que
nous avons élaboré en commun un projet
c'est aussi un cas qui donne du sens à
la vie en commun des français et pour
moi pour moi ce cap pour la france et
pour les français il et il fera toujours
inspiré des fondamentaux du gaullisme
je ne parle pas ici soyez en sûrs de ce
gaullisme du bout des lèvres dont chacun
ou dont beaucoup aujourd'hui
se réclament y compris c'est un comble
un françois hollande où certains membres
du front national je ne vous parle pas
d'un gaullisme de nostalgie je ne vous
parle pas d'un gaullisme qui serait une
boîte à outils d'il y à 50 ans que l'on
voudrait utiliser pour les problèmes
d'aujourd'hui
non le gaullisme de gens vous parlent
c'est celui qui rassemble qui rassemble
tous les partisans de la france qui
rassemble au delà des différences au
delà même des appartenances partisanes
celui qui porte une ambition pour la
france
la vision d'un avenir du pays dans un
monde qui se construit
le gaullisme du pragmatisme au plus près
des réalités
le gaullisme qui met l'homme au coeur de
son projet
c'est cette vision du monde qui nous
entoure cette prospective
cette volonté indéfectible d'assurer la
grandeur de la france c'est le bonheur
des français qu'ils doivent fixer le cap
d'un projet présidentiel donner du sens
à toutes les mesures que nous proposons
c'est un projet politique mais est aussi
un projet social
c'est un projet ambitieux et c'est un
projet réaliste
alors évitons chers amis d'abord
l'écueil de la démagogie et de
nombrilisme
n'oublions jamais que la france n'est
pas seule
la france n'est pas seule dans le monde
dans le monde elle a des alliés elle a
des amis mais là aussi des ennemis et
elle a des concurrents
alors oui peut-on faire des propositions
sur la sécurité sans comprendre ce
qu'est l'art et
lutter au moyen orient au maghreb ou
même à l'est de notre continent
peut-on parler d'immigration cher alain
sans tenir compte de la réalité
démographique de l'afrique passé de 477
millions d'habitants en 1981 1 milliard
aujourd'hui à 2 milliards en 2080
peut-on traiter de l'économie ou de
l'emploi sans mesurer la concurrence des
immenses pays que sont la chine ou lève
ou plus près de nous la concurrence de
nos partenaires européens
oui tous les sujets que nous abordons
qu'il s'agisse d'économie qu'il s'agisse
d'emploi qu'il s'agisse de social qu'il
s'agisse d'éducation qu'il s'agisse de
culture ne doit pas être regardé à
l'aune de la prochaine échéance
électorale
ils doivent faire l'objet d'une vision
d'une vision prospective
parlons de prospective un peu plus à 10
à 15 à 30 ans et si nous regardons cela
alors là oui nous pouvons nous rendre
compte que nous avons toutes les raisons
d'avoir confiance dans notre pays et
d'avoir confiance en nous certes on doit
pas dire le contraire parce qu'il faut
dire la réalité aux français
notre pays a des handicaps un certain
nombre de handicaps naturels sa taille
sa démographie à un peu vieillissante
son absence de ressources énergétiques
mais aussi des handicaps politiques et
notamment grâce à la gauche depuis un
bon nombre d'années entre les 35 heures
la sueur fiscalisation la
surréglementation oui tout ceci ce sont
des handicaps mais la france a aussi des
atouts et des atouts considérables pour
le monde de demain
dans un monde qui va être de plus en
plus nombreux et y avoir de moins en
moins de terres cultivables
n'oublions jamais que notre agriculture
et notre industrie agroalimentaire sont
l'une des premières exportatrices du
monde dans un monde qui va avoir de plus
en plus besoin de communication de
communication physique mais
elle manque de communication
dématérialisés avec l'informatique avec
le numérique
n'oublions pas que la france et est un
leader en matière d'aviation comme en
matière de spatiale à l'heure où la
préoccupation du monde c'est de vivre de
plus en plus longtemps mais aussi dans
de meilleurs en deux avec une santé de
meilleur en meilleur n'oublions pas que
nous avons des industries de santé des
industries pharmaceutiques qui sont
parmi les toutes premières
n'oublions pas notre domaine maritime le
premier au monde
n'oublions pas notre présence sur les
cinq continents grâce à nos territoires
et départements d'outre-mer
n'oublions pas le savoir faire que nous
trouvons y compris dans les pme je le
constate chaque jour où nous avons des
pépites qui deviennent des leaders
mondiaux oui chers amis c'est la france
que vous applaudissez la france de
demain qui a vocation à être toujours un
leader dans le monde
mais pour mettre ses atouts en oeuvre
nous avons besoin d'une politique et
notamment d'une politique économique
alors je vais être clair avec vous je
suis désolé mais ça va peut-être
déranger certains mais je ne comprends
pas très bien aujourd'hui la mode qui
consiste dans une surenchère libérables
moi je veux dire que ce que je crois
c'est qu'il faut rendre à l'entreprise
qui relève de sa mission
c'est à dire ce qui permet la création
de richesses et donc la paix la création
de véritables emplois et pour cela c'est
vrai il faut la libérer de tout ce qui
consiste en des distorsions de
concurrence et que représente dans notre
pays les charges fiscales sociales
réglementaire bien supérieures y compris
à celles de nos concurrents européens
parce que ce sont les gouvernements
socialistes et les administrations qui
en rajoute
il faut libérer les ambitions et la
créativité en remettant de la souplesse
dans tout ça en allégeant les rigidités
mais il faut dans le même temps rendre à
l'état ce qui lui revient
c'est à dire son rôle de stratège
garante de l'intérêt général dans la
durée et des orientations majeures
c'est à lui que revient l'action
planifièrent moyen et à long terme pour
lancer les grandes orientations qui vont
être celle des leaders industriels que
nous représenterons dans le monde
c'est à lui qu'il revient de garantir un
aménagement du territoire ou entreprises
comme particuliers où qu'il soit sur
notre territoire national ont les mêmes
chances la même possibilité de créer
c'est à lui d'assurer l'unité de la
nation à travers la reconnaissance de
chacun dans sa vie d'homme dans sa vie
de salarié dans sa vie de citoyen chers
amis c'est vrai que nous avons été un
pays qui a montré le chemin
nous devons leur devenir et ce cap les
français doit le comprendre il doit se
décliner dans tous les domaines alors
j'aurais aimé chez reluque vous parlé de
bien d'autres domaines justement ceux de
l'autorité de l'état
ceux de la culture qui est fondamental à
notre pacte national ceux de la
responsabilité qui doit être le
corollaire de la liberté ceux de la
fraternité qui doit unir les français
mais j'avais on m'avait dit dix minutes
7 minutes c'est bien court pour tout
abordé mais je n'en doute pas nous
aurons dans les semaines et les mois à
venir bien d'autres occasions de nous
rencontrer pour débattre de ces
différences sujet est ce nous le ferons
parce que c'est ensemble que nous ferons
partager nos convictions à tous les
français et au delà des clivages
politiques
parce que ce qui nous réunit c'est que
nous voulons les uns et les autres en
étant chacun un militant de nos idées
c'est en sorte de recréer chez tous nos
concitoyens l'envi de partager un destin
commun
un destin qui n'est pas notre destin
personnel un destin quel destin de ceux
qui nous dépasse tous c'est ce qui nous
réunit c'est à dire la france merci